In the last few
videos, we've been
talking about the
production possibilities
frontier as a relatively
static thing, something
that you couldn't change
but you could move along.
What I want to do in this
video is think about,
maybe there are ways
to change or expand
the production
possibilities frontier.
And to do that let's assume that
our little hunter-gatherer has
decided to become
a strict carnivore.
So he's only focused
on rabbits now.
And his whole happiness in
life is optimizing the number
of rabbits he can catch
and eat in a given day.
And so let's-- on
one axis let's draw,
let's say the number of rabbits
that he can catch in a given
day.
Let's say it's 1,
2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7--
I could keep going on and on.
So this right over
here is rabbits
that he can catch in a
given day, rabbits in a day.
But remember, he wants
to optimize this.
He wants to think about how he
can increase his productivity
in terms of the
number of rabbits.
And he knows-- we'll
just assume that he
knows how to build rabbit traps.
So now we're going to do
a production possibilities
frontier, not between
rabbits and berries,
but between rabbits and building
rabbit traps, so rabbit traps.
So maybe he's able
to get twigs together
and he builds something.
Puts the twigs together
in a little thing.
It's a little box that--
maybe he puts a little,
I don't know some type of
carrot down over there.
And then if the rabbit comes
then takes the carrot then
the box falls on the rabbit
or something like that.
We don't have to go into the
particulars of the actual trap.
But he can also spends his
time building rabbit traps.
So let's say, 1 rabbit
trap, 2 rabbit traps,
and 3 rabbit traps.
And let's say-- we're going to
hold all other things equal,
ceteris parabus.
So we're not worrying
about other things.
And as we'll see, in most
introductory economics class,
whenever you do a production
possibilities frontier
you're only doing it
with two dimensions.
And so that's why you
have a regular curve.
You could have one with three
dimensions, where you're
doing the trade off
between three things.
But then you would have to
have a three dimensional graph,
and essentially the production
possibilities frontier
would be a surface.
But let's just focus
on this right now.
Maybe I'll do a surface in
the future, just for fun.
So these are the rabbit traps.
And let's say the production
possibilities frontier
between rabbit traps and rabbits
look something like this.
He could spend all his
time making rabbit traps,
but in that case he
won't get any rabbits
and he'll probably starve.
And that wouldn't
be a good scenario.
Or he could spend all of
this time hunting for rabbits
and he would catch, on
average, 5 rabbits per day.
But that would leave him no
time to make rabbit traps.
So this is our
current production
possibilities-- let
me just draw it.
This is our current production
possibilities frontier.
So I'll call this p, production
And I'll put a little
0 subscript there.
That's our starting point.
So he can he can sit
anywhere over here,
and he would have achieved
productive efficiency anywhere
on this curve.
But as we saw, if he just spent
all of his time doing this
over here, he'll never
get any rabbit traps.
And so he won't
be able to change
the productive
possibility frontier.
But what happens if
instead he decides
that he does want to
build some rabbit traps?
So he decreases the number
of rabbits a day to 4
and that allows him to
make 1 rabbit trap per day.
So he wants to hang
out in this scenario.
So every day that
goes by, on average,
he's going to make 4 rabbits.
And he's going to
build a rabbit trap.
So what's going to happen?
So as we go into, maybe
into the next period,
he would now have a rabbit
trap after just one day
that he can use to
help catch rabbits.
So that will actually change
the production possibilities
frontier.
So if he makes
this investment, it
will actually allow him,
in a given amount of time,
to actually catch more rabbits.
So if he does that, the
production possibilities
frontier-- having a rabbit
trap won't make him that much,
won't allow him to make
more rabbit traps in a day.
So the most rabbit traps
he can make in a day
is still going to be 3.
But maybe now he can
catch 6 rabbits a day.
So now it might look
something like that.
So now he could either
stop making rabbit traps,
and catch 6 a day just
with that 1 rabbit trap
he has, or he could
continue that.
And now actually he can
catch 5 rabbits a day
and still make 1
rabbit trap a day.
And maybe he decides to do that.
But it could be anywhere along
this production possibilities
frontier.
Or he could say, hey, I'm happy
eating the 4 rabbits a day.
I'm going to make 2 rabbit
traps now every day.
And now after another period
he gets even more productive.
And so then the production--
so let me call this one,
this is after one day.
Production possibilities
frontier after one day,
and then after two
days, let's say
he did this scenario
right over here.
Now he's produce 2 rabbit traps.
And obviously, maybe I'm
exaggerating how quickly
his productivity would grow.
But maybe now the new production
possibilities frontier
looks something like this.
He now has 2 rabbit traps.
Or he has 2 more rabbit
traps, he already had 1.
So now he has 3 rabbit
traps after two days.
And so now if he wanted to
devote themselves purely
to rabbit trapping he
can get 8 rabbits a day.
Or he could do some
combination in between.
And actually this curve,
it shouldn't go up at all.
I don't want to give
you the impression
that it went up and then down.
It just goes kind of
straight and does something
like that right over here.
So this right over
here, I'll call
that the production
possibilities frontier 2.
So what this hunter-gatherer
is doing in this scenario
right here is, he is
making an investment.
He is accumulating capital.
This right over here,
this is capital.
He is choosing, instead of to
consume all of his resources--
so there's two things he can do.
He can either spend all of
his time in pure consumption,
getting as many rabbits
as possible a day
and then eating them
all, pure consumption.
Or he could reduce
his consumption
and then allocate
some of his resources
towards and investment.
So this right over here,
this is an investment.
It makes him more productive.
This right over
here is consumption.
There's some base
level of consumption
he needs to survive.
But if he invests,
then it increases
his overall productive capacity.
So if you viewed
him as an economy
by himself, by investing
instead of consuming
all of his resources,
by investing
some of his resources--
and in this case,
his resources are his
time and his expertise--
by investing some of them
he's able to increase
his productivity.
And if you viewed
him as an economy,
he's experiencing
economic growth.
And so there's multiple
types of investments.
And we'll talk about
these in multiple videos.
In this case, he is doing
capital accumulation.
He is building tools that
will make him more productive.
Another type of
investment is essentially
technological change,
technological improvement,
which would actually make
his tools even better.
So we could maybe draw another
production possibilities
frontier between
making rabbit traps
and then doing R&D on inventing
new types of rabbit traps.
And so he could decide
which of those two things
he wants to decide between.
But what I wanted you to
just appreciate in this video
is that the production
possibilities
frontier can change.
You can become more
productive if you
do have investment in R&D
or capital accumulation.
And in this case, that just
happened to be rabbit traps.